i could not be more excited for your
series um just want to start with that
just so amped up for this one um if
someone has actually never seen any star
wars can they watch this series or do
you want to recommend the things they
need to watch
to like really get ready for it you know
that's an interesting question i would
definitely say that would help if you've
seen the prequels um you know so i think
if you're gonna if you do have time to
watch one thing the prequels would would
certainly be a help in in understanding
the show
um you know it's tricky because
obviously we are so in the middle of two
trilogies with these big legacy
characters but as much as possible you
know joby who's the writer and i when we
were doing the development we really
were trying to make sure that you know
we'd always do a reality check to go if
we take the star wars out of this does
this still work just on a human level so
you know i guess if you didn't know
anything at all about star wars which
feels like it could be hard to find a
person who maybe doesn't know anything
um
i think you could still watch it you may
not get every single reference or
understand everything but i think it's
hopefully it still works just on a human
level how close did darth maul come to
being in the series from the time that
i've been involved honestly darth maul
has never actually been part of the
conversation um so i'm not sure if it
was improv i've never seen it actually
in any iteration that i've been involved
with i'm assuming obviously you must
have spent a lot of time researching and
learning everything you could learn
was there one thing in particular that
you found that you're like oh my god
this is cool and this is going in the
series
um you know it's interesting because you
know i'd obviously done a lot of you
know um
gone pretty deep for mandalorian but
this was you know then i went very deep
for kenobi and i really looked at a lot
of the stuff in the extended universe
and especially connected to stuff that
you know we might touch on
um so it's interesting you know there's
a lot of great stuff out there but i
think you know one thing that
was really it did it was quite
meaningful was there's a statue of
kenobi during this period
um a sideshow statue that it really sort
of felt visually like it encapsulated
what the feel of the character was at
this moment and that actually became
quite a reference that i would continue
to go back and look at visually was it
an older statue i'm your appreciative
statue yeah i don't have the exact name
but um
it's it's quite a beautiful statue so it
was really it just sort of had the feel
and you know so much as what you're
trying to do as a filmmaker is you're
you're trying to
you know what does this feel like what's
the tone of this series and it felt like
it came close uh the series is six
episodes
and the thing about disney plus is some
episodes some series are like 30 minutes
and some series are an hour so i'm very
curious how long are the episodes um
it's definitely a range and it depends
on you know the story being told i think
with each episode so it ranges uh you
know per episode but you know
everything's under an hour when it's all
said and done how long is it do you know
like is it four hours is it five hours i
don't even know honestly
i i i could do the math but i i think
maybe it would be better if we waited
until after the show came out to get
into
say no more did you end up with a lot of
deleted scenes or is it one of these
things where it all went on the screen
you know it's interesting almost
everything was on the screen there was
very little actually that that got cut
um so
you know and obviously we were we were
shooting this through cove and it's
quite an ambitious project so it was
kind of great actually at the end of the
day that um the
vast majority of what we shot actually
is on screen which episode of the six
are you really amped up for fans to see
uh you know it's interesting like every
episode especially after you work on
something so long you know they all have
sort of a place in your heart um but i
think you know the final episode because
you bring everything together in the
final episode you know i'm excited for
the fans to get there and see the whole
journey come to it's to its end uh
obviously like everyone loves the
lightsaber fights in star wars what is
it like actually trying to
bring cool lightsaber fights to your
series and i'm curious if you could talk
a little bit about the collaboration
with whoever your second unit director
was i actually don't know how like what
is that relationship like how much were
you trying to do it you know what i mean
um you know for action i i truly love
doing action and you know obviously you
know we i had done a bunch on
mandalorian but it was mostly blaster
fire so it was a lot of shootouts and
then all of a sudden i'm going into a
lot of lightsaber stuff but
i mean for me honestly for this series i
tried to do the vast majority of it
because it's something i feel actually
is very important to do um i did have an
amazing stunt stunt coordinator jojo
estubio who very much was with me and we
court you know we creatively
collaborated to you know on the
choreography and got there and he
definitely helped it on the second unit
um but i think the the thing for me
that's always made action feel the
strongest is when it comes out of
character and that it's not just action
for action's sake um so it's something
that i feel is is quite important of
making sure that the character and all
the emotion is there at the same time as
the action and the physicality can you
talk a little bit about trying to i
don't know about raising the bar but
like how you wanted you know
certain sequences to elevate for you
know like standout moments if you will
um yeah i mean i think with you know in
terms of approaching the action
especially with the lightsaber stuff
like obviously with the inquisitors
we're into a whole new set of you know
lightsabers and different actions that
we haven't seen in live action that was
pretty exciting um i will say it is far
easier to spin a lightsaber animation
than it is in you know in live action so
that was a bit of a trick but um you
know i think with the just in terms of
the approach on it
you know you want the
you want the scenes to feel very dynamic
and you know you want to get the heart
rate up and we're all excited to kind of
get to do them and to see them but at
the same time
one of the things that's so interesting
about it is that because of the nature
of the fight and the characters it's
personal and it there is really a lot
going on with this this is not just a
fight this is two know two characters
involved that really mean something to
each other so um that to me is always
the heart of doing the best action yeah
i gotta stop i'm just gonna say
sincerely i am
so excited to see this series i wish you
nothing but the best thank you so much